ich möchte nur weiterkommen als letztes
mal hallo mein name ist luca und wir
spielen nochmals länder die menschen
ließ marburger einer besseren grafik
viele mein simyo als letzte mal ein lied
gesungen hat nichts doch voll gut ins
länder
enderlein glas mehr war ein geiles bein
ich hab' ich bin versuche ich das jetzt
wieder ich habe da auch schon kleinen
sechs vorbereitet flender ich hasse dich
denn du bist dein arsch gesicht ich
trete hier in den weichteilen rein
das war's ich krieg jetzt schon angst
obwohl ich die noch nicht mal gesehen
habe aber hier ist glaub ich schon das
erste mal dass sich länder setzen schon
dass das erste momentum sei hier ist das
erste moment um dieses spiel ich
entferne mich immer weiter vom pc es
schimmert schon wieder so behindert da
sind moment um das momentum ok
einzelansicht mondays ich weiß mein
englisch eskaliert immer so ein bisschen
wenn ich auf eine über abend da ist ja
okay das sagt er ist hat man noch
er ist ja immer noch
dahinter kommen das ist doch nicht mehr
witzig wenn kollege ich will nur meine
eine toilette hallo hallo toilette
das ist immer so ein grippe behandelt
ich drehe mich gar nicht um denn ich bin
so sturm
wie ein kleine missgeburt ich fick dich
und bleibt ganz ruhig wenn ich dann noch
weiter geht bin ich fast schon im dem
schnee ich hasse es länder man warum
spiele ich das wenn ich das ist doch
alle fall amanda hafer dass ich möchte
nur weiterkommen als letztes mal
es funktioniert nicht mein licht ich
schmeiße diesen klaus sticken und nichts
läuft
ich will da nicht runter ich will da
nicht lang hohmann und wer hier steht
jetzt wieder so ein blöder ausländer
jetzt habe ich gerade whatsapp bekommen
habe ich es trocken ich drehe mich nicht
um
okay da legst du kleine lou krieg aber
jetzt ist das hier schon wieder alles zu
krass am wackeln
ach du jetzt verfolgt nämlich auch noch
man das ist doch nicht noch nicht wieder
wahr sein hier war ich doch überall
schon dieses spiel ist so scheiße und
simpel aber als gerd den held steht auch
hier bin ich wieder ein bisschen
ausgerastet mit meinem ganzen groß ist
kann ich so schwierig sein die da ist
schon wieder der kleine das kann doch
nicht du bist doch auch ist es soll
erhält nicht mal mehr witzig dass er
mich verfolgt was bringen war ob diese
classics es bringt einfach nichts
ich schmeiß die dahin und es fängt
einfach es leuchtet das was bringen
diese teile
es bringt ihr was soll ich mit euch
jetzt zwei kommt so volksdorf ich die
ganze zeit nur im maghreb aqim kreis
hallo
nein nein nein enderlein ich hab dir auf
den beinen wenn du wiederkommst kein
schwein an weil scheine sind eigentlich
toll hier sieht böse aus gehen weil
damals davon leuchtet irgendwas ich will
da nicht rein ich sehe einfach nichts
was soll das denn ich kann ja nicht zehn
letztens war wenigstens noch nicht an
einfach nichts ist da was 3 von 12 mm 8
o heilige wir sind besser als letztes
mal da geht es runter da geht runter da
geht runter da haben wir auf jeden fall
ein schlüsselloch für ich mag das was
ihr nicht mögt schalala es geht sich
daraufhin weiter oder habt ihr euch dann
auch erschrocken bitte nicht beantworten
die frage hallo alles klar bei euch wie
geht es euch sonst so hier unten ist
alle spitze oder also bei mir ist es
halt so dass ich mir jetzt jeden moment
denke dass sie einfach karten
ich finde es auch nicht witzig
eigentlich ich habe den abt ihren
ländern angesehen in der stelle
oder ich ohne die so kommst du denn dann
du kleiner verstehe ich nicht jetzt mal
ohne spaß habt ihr da gerade ins länder
man gesehen dass spieler wie mich doch
verarschen ja freunde wenn es euch
trotzdem gefahren hat würde ich mich
über eine bewertung freuen nächstes mal
versuchen wir dann vier seiten zu finden
hätte ich eh nicht schaffen denn ihr
weitere horror spiele oder das
länderspiel oder irgendwas was ich mal
zocken soll dann schwarz mit kommentare